we've got breaking news from London and
it's good Prince William and his wife
Kate are parents of a new baby boy the
Duchess delivered her third child this
morning Roxana Saberi is outside st.
Mary's Hospital Roxana what have you
heard good morning good morning well
according to that treat tweet from
Kensington Palace the baby boy weighs 8
pounds and 7 ounces and was born just
about two hours ago at 11:01 a.m. local
time
Prince William the baby's father was
present and the tweet also says that
mother and son are doing well Kate's
last official appearance was at a
charity event for athletes in March but
Lexie her here on the steps of the Lindo
wing at London's st. Mary's Hospital
with her new arrival royal biographer
Robert Hardman says it's cause for
celebration it's time when the whole
country can just sort of put aside
day-to-day political bickering and just
really be happy for what's just a happy
family engagement we we they are our
family effectively it's the same
hospital where Princess Diana and Prince
Charles welcomed Princes William and
Harry it's also where William and Kate
introduced Prince George to the world in
2013
[Music]
and it's where the young prince returned
nearly two years later to meet his new
baby's sister Charlotte like all royal
babies the latest addition can expect to
melt hearts and make headlines when seen
by the public
which isn't often William and Kate have
closely guarded their children's privacy
so where will Kate and William's third
child stand in line to the throne Prince
Charles is first in line then his son
Prince William Prince George's third and
Princess Charlotte fourth the new
arrival will be fifth in line Prince
William's brother Harry will now be
sixth but he didn't seem to mind being
demoted when asked in 2014 not long
before Charlotte was born and of course
with that growing family your prospects
of becoming King we reduced anything we
may not know the baby's name for a
couple of days but ARDS odds are that
his name could be Arthur or Albert which
would be the name of the current Queen's
father John Roxana Saberi in London
thanks oyez oyez it's a boy yay yeah
very good also know the boy's name isn't
going to be Otis it's going to be
something that is very traditional with
the royal family did you said earlier
nor we just want a healthy baby yeah and
if it's Arthur that's a good solid royal
darling yes yeah I got for the swords in
this tone yeah right